[Musique]
maintenant, je pense que le gabarit est prêt pour un Wallace
Avery, cet ampèremètre autrefois prometteur ne peut pas
gérer la grosse tonne et j'entends qu'il ne peut pas
se ressaisir non plus, bonjour
April, tu sais ce qui est si triste à ce sujet,
il est un peu  super quelle
histoire d'Arthur et Arthur J Newman Je suis un pro du golf
Tiger Woods où voudriez-vous que
je vous emmène, vérifions qu'il est
entré par effraction dans les maisons des gens ou leurs
vêtements en choisissant leurs lits
Je suis Arthur Newman frère de golf Je t'appelle ma
femme  dans un pro enlève cette chose tu l'
enlèves
belle chaise chérie mec
reste avec moi un luxe tu connais une
femme nommée Charlotte Fitzgerald
probablement tu penses vraiment que tu es la
seule personne avec la carte d'identité de quelqu'un d'autre gros
problème Wallace m'as-tu appelé avis  comme
ne perdez-vous pas ce que vous pensiez
ne pas vouloir
passer le reste de votre vie à vouloir le
récupérer ceux qui veulent la même chose pasteur
Newman world